in this video we're going to do with the
hyperbola the exact same thing we did
with the circle we're going to find
constraints on the y-intercept for the
tangent line in terms of m but this time
we're going to use a hyperbola and then
we can set them equal to each other and
solve for the m so let's remind
ourselves what the equation of the
hyperbola is they give it to us right
over there it's x squared over 9 minus y
squared over 4 is equal to 1. let me
write this over here so it is
x squared over 9
minus y squared over 4 is equal to
is equal i'll write the y squared minus
y squared over 4 is equal to 1. but now
we can substitute the y squared with the
y is equal to mx plus b that we got from
the last video and we actually figured
out what y squared was equal to y
squared was equal to all of this
business up here because it's the same
line remember this is the whole point of
it we're trying to find two constraints
on that same line so we can rewrite this
same thing and actually one thing i want
to do is i'm going to multiply both
sides of this equation by 36 the common
multiple of 9 and 4 so that i can get
rid of these fractions and so this is
going to become
this is going to become 36 let me write
it this way
so 36 divided by 9 is 4 so it's 4 x
squared
minus 36 divided by 4 is 9
and i would put a y squared here but we
know that y squared is the exact same
thing as this thing over here
so y squared is the same thing as m
squared x squared plus two
m b x plus b squared and then this is
going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to remember we
multiplied both sides of this equation
by 36 so this is going to be equal to
equal to 36 and let me simplify this
we're going to do the exact same thing
we know we know that uh we know that m
and
we know that the m and b have to be such
that or the line has to have it as a
slope and y intercept will only
intersect with the hyperbola at one
point it'll only have one solution to
this quadratic in terms of x but let's
simplify it first before we worry about
that so this is equal to
4 x squared
minus 9
m squared x squared minus 18 minus 18
m
b x
minus 9
minus 9 b squared just multiply it there
and let me subtract this 36 from both
sides so then we have minus 36 is equal
to zero so this is a quadratic in terms
of x but let me combine let me
combine the the various degree terms so
this these are the x squared terms
these are the x squared terms right over
here so this is the same thing as
4 minus 9 m squared
times x squared and then our only x term
is this right over here that's our only
x term so this is minus 18 m bx and then
our constant terms
our constant terms are right over here
so this over here is
minus 9
minus 9 b squared
minus 9 b squared let me write it this
way let me write it as minus 9
minus 9
let me write it as
let me write it as well i'll just write
it minus 9 b squared minus 36 i'll just
write like that and of course that is
going to be equal to 0.
and remember quadratic formula if we
wanted to solve for the x's we would
have the quadratic formula but we only
want to have one solution so the
discriminant part of the quadratic
formula is going to equal zero the b
squared minus 4ac is going to be equal
to zero that's exactly what we did in
the last video so let's take the b
squared minus four ac and set that equal
to zero and then we'll have our our our
m our constraints on m and b
so b squared
is
and remember don't get the b squared in
the quadratic formula confused with the
b in the y-intercept but this term
squared is so this is going to be it's
going to be 18
squared
m squared
b squared right negative 18 squared is
just positive 18
minus 4
times a
a is 4 minus 9 m squared times c
times c so c is so i can rewrite c as
negative
negative nine
times
what is this negative nine times b
squared
b squared plus four did i do that right
negative nine times b squared is
negative nine b squared negative 9 times
4 is negative 36. i want to make sure i
don't make any careless mistakes and so
this becomes so if we just took the
negative 9 and the negative 4
they become a positive 36
and then we can actually
let's see just to simplify things so we
don't have to do too much fancy math
this 18 squared let's remember let's
remember 18 squared is the same thing
is
well 18 squared is going to be divisible
well i won't worry too much about that
just yet i just want to make sure that
actually let me let me write it this way
so 18 squared is 2
2 times 9 times 2 times 9. or another
way to think about it is 4
times 9 times 9 that's the same thing as
18 squared 4 times 9 times 9.
now we can divide both of these terms we
can and this whole thing remember we
want this whole thing to be equal to
zero the discriminant has to be equal to
zero so we can divide both sides of this
equation we can divide both sides of the
equation by 36 which is the same thing
as dividing by four times 9. so this
term right over here we can get rid of 1
4 and 1 9 and we're going to get
we're going to get a 9
9 m squared b squared over here and then
we divided by 36 so these all go away so
it's going to be 9 m squared b squared
plus this thing
times this thing plus this thing times
this thing so let's see what that is
so we have a 4 times a b squared so we
have plus 4 b squared let me do this in
a different color
4 do it in blue so plus
4 b squared and you have 4 times 4 so
plus 16 then you have negative 9 m
squared times b squared so it's negative
nine m squared
b squared and then you have negative
nine m squared times four so negative 36
negative 36 m squared and that's going
to be equal to zero lucky for us that
and that cancel out and then we are left
with
we are left with
something and actually what we're left
with everything is divisible by 4. so
let's divide what we're left with by 4
so then we're left with b squared
b squared that's that term and then
minus nine m squared minus
minus nine m squared
that's that term over there just divided
by four
and then plus 4
plus 4 is equal to 0
and once again we could use
we could well actually here we don't
have to do anything we'd have to use
quadratic formula we could just solve
for b we could add
we could subtract this from both sides
and so we'll get b squared
b squared is equal to the square root
the square root of 9
m
squared square root of 9m squared
minus
square root of 9 m squared minus 4.
sorry that's not b b is equal let me
just write this i don't want to skip
steps here
b is equal to this b squared is equal to
9 m squared
minus 4. they're painting the office
right now so maybe it's making me a
little bit making my brain not work
properly and then b
is equal to the square root of 9 m
squared minus four did i do that right
let's see i got the four
yeah it looks right
and so we're left with the situation
where the b if we're if we're saying the
line is tangent to the hyperbola has to
be this and if the line is tangent to
the circle b has to be equal to this
this business over here
so let me copy it
and then let me paste it
let me paste it just like that and so we
now have two equations with two unknowns
we can set these equal to each other and
solve for m and this will give us the
the m or the slope of that tangent line
and then we can go ahead and solve for b
i'll do that in the next video